es ist ja erst was diese gerichte die
sind alle erst mal eine frieden
anerkannter text dass ich wurde
ausgebildet in der krasseste levels es
gibt schon wirklich auch noch
weil ich dich auf teilweise
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir sind
fleisch aber geschmort aus dem backofen
richtig schön zart und das ist auch
wieder so eine idee wenn ihr besuch
bekommt gerade jetzt zu den anstehenden
feiertagen ist es halt so ja kinder
geschmortes aus dem backofen geht immer
liegt jeder und vor allem eines sein am
ende richtig zeit ist dann habt ihr
sowieso pluspunkte jackpot guck mal hier
wir fangen jetzt an ich habe meinen
rindfleisch vorab ich würde mal sagen
vier zentimeter dicke stücke geschnitten
also es ist nicht mundgerecht man kann
jetzt nicht in einem haps essen aber ich
möchte das so dann kann man es auf dem
teller nochmals auseinander ziehen aber
die größe ist euch überlassen
ich starte jetzt direkt ihr wisst bei
mir findet ihr alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten denn der in fribourg
in der infobox so und ich fange jetzt
einfach an mit meinem fleisch hier habe
ich meinen topf da gebe ich diesmal
kokosfett rein aus dem grund da er
kokosfett hoch erhitzen könnt dann nehme
ich meinen bio kokosfett eigentlich
kennt ihr aus meinen anderen videos
nämlich dass die suggerierte das hat
auch die gleichen eigenschaften ist nur
geschmacks und geruchsneutral das ist
die premiere alle weil ich das wie ein
weltmeister benutzer deswegen nämlich
hier kokosöl und jetzt das fleisch ohne
salz und pfeffer einfach scharf von
allen seiten kurz anbraten und dabei ist
mir wichtig dass ihr also ich gebe das
fleisch erst mal direkt rein wir die
sauberen hände dabei ist mir wichtig
dass ihr es wirklich dann erst löst wenn
quasi ist sich von alleine löst also
wenn es so klebt am topfboden dann ist
es halt noch nicht so weit und nicht
übereinander stapeln sondern wirklich
eine fleisch kurz braten und dann die
nächste immer wieder rausnehmen bis sie
das fleisch komplett durchgebraten habe
also nicht durchgebraten sondern bis ihr
es wirklich außen kurz kross gebraten
[Musik]
das fleisch dürft ihr dann im topf zu
salzen und pfeffern
der grund warum ich das nicht vorab
schon mache ist der dass wenn ihr euer
fleischpreise liegen habt salz und
pfeffer und danach und nach anbraten
dann ist das die letzte partie quasi
schon gesalzen und eigentlich sollte man
fleisch nicht ganz so lange stehen
lassen wenn schon salz drauf ist oder er
macht im gegenteil ihr macht quasi ohne
salzschicht und lass es sein in zwei
stunden einziehen das wieder was anderes
aber in meinem fall geht ihr so auf
nummer sicher jetzt habe ich einmal
komplett raus geholt und in der gleichen
fahne ich habe übrigens hier meine hoch
an fahne die verleger ich euch gerne in
der infobox da geben wir jetzt unser
paprika markt hinein und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr auf tomatenmark nehmen
aber ich finde paprika markt schmeckt
noch mal so ein bisschen besonders und
das ist nicht das gleiche wie war das
habe ich nämlich letztens mal gelesen
ich weiß kann ich meinen ausspricht das
ist diese scharte passte
kennst du dich so hast du typisch
ja so ähnlich aber das ist auf jeden
fall paprika markt gibt es in der süßen
und in der scharfen variante ich mir mal
gemüse variante und da kommen jetzt mal
richtig schön röstaromen raus ihr habt
ja auch noch rest fährt ihr habt auch
noch rest aroma quasi vom fleisch
richtig schön anbraten und ich habe
nebenbei schalotten in halbe-halbe ringe
geschnitten die gebe ich auch schon mit
dazu und dann kommt auch noch knoblauch
mit rein
[Musik]
also gerade sich das fleisch noch bei
hoher hitze schön angebraten aber
hierfür müsst ihr wirklich runter gehen
stufe 5 das ist wirklich nur so dünstet
auch wirklich nur so 23 minuten und ich
habe auch noch guten schuss olivenöl mit
rein gegeben weil man merkels okay es
ist nicht mehr viel fett drin was macht
man jetzt entweder gibt man wieder
kokosfett oder alternativ irgendein hoch
erhitztes fett rein oder man gibt
olivenöl rein weil der geschmack einfach
stimmt und das ist noch mal so ein
bisschen aufgepeppt und apropos
olivenöl aus palästina was unseres jahr
ist muss sich gerade ein übergang aber
wirklich gerade während der pause um
sich so daran denken dass ich von hamms
mama wie es ja auch palästinenserin dass
ich von ihr gerade so was kochen mit
fleisch angeht sehr viel gelernt habe
weil ich sah meine türkischen küche ist
ja auch wieder ein bisschen anders als
in der arabischen küche und durch diese
beschlüsse
darüber lässt sich jetzt streiten oder
gelacht also jede küche hat seine
vorzüge das ist die küche schreib doch
mal jetzt die reihen ich bin sogar
volllaufen korea trip übrigens mehr
koreaner sprich koreanische blogs
verlinkt ich euch mal hier unten auch
könnt ihr euch mal angucken
ich bin so schlimm bitte erinnert mich
freuen wenn ich das vergessen football
auf jeden fall gibt es einen wird jetzt
passt man auch meine arabische skills
sind richtig und es nennt sich selber
kabarett hat
[Gelächter]
das ist mein sieben gewürze gewürz mix
quasi und da sind richtig orientalische
zutaten mit drin die auch super zugleich
passen paprika anis fenchel kümmel
pfeffer und zimt und jahr sind mit
fleisch passt wunderbar auch in meinem
ersten mal denke hey es passt publikum
gegen tauss worauf ich hinaus möchte ich
gebe jetzt ein fleisch zurück in die
pfanne wo ich mit dem ganzen sache ist
natürlich ein bisschen was ausgetreten
aber durch das scharf anbraten
verhindern wir dass das später alles
austritt dass so wenig wie möglich
austritt und das schön saftig bleibt und
jetzt kommt herr barbara hatte
sebahat sei aber auf jeden fall habe ich
das jetzt hier mit gewürz jetzt fragt
ihr euch mit mir ausmachen wenn ich das
nicht habe kann ich davon ausgehen dass
jeder meinen gewürz zu hause
dann nimmt ihr stattdessen gemüsebrühe
es schmeckt dann natürlich nicht genauso
aber das ist eine abwandlung die
schmeckt dann nicht ganz so
orientalische war das ist auch okay ich
schon dass gutes so sorgt das war ja das
ist mir wichtig dass man nicht den ball
habe ich diese eine sache nichts
kingsley
jetzt haben
[Musik]
sich also ich muss sagen es gibt auch
bei es ist nicht so dass jedes 7 geburt
gleich schmecken gleichen anteil hat ich
hab doch schon das ding sie habe keine
viel sonne genau ich kann ja viel
einfluss nehmen was wovon wie viel vom
was kommt reinkommt geht er richtig
deutsch gelernt hier so salz und pfeffer
kommt auch noch dazu und dann gar nicht
weiter an braten oder so ich bin nur
dass die gewürze sich gut miteinander
verbinden mit dem fleisch also gar nicht
lang anbraten nur kurz miteinander so
verrühren übrigens den ofen schon
vorgeheizt das hier kommt jetzt noch mit
dazu einfach nur wasser und achtet beim
wasser drauf dass das jetzt nicht wie
kalt ist macht auch warmes wasser rein
damit der temperaturunterschied nötig
ist so und jetzt als ich das noch einmal
richtig schön erhitzen das ist einmal
probiert und dann kommt der deckel drauf
aha
lorbeerblätter fast ja diese vergessen
ab sondern im augenwinkel gesehen hier
wände ganz nervös heute kommt jetzt auch
noch mit dazu gehört gerne auch noch
salz abschmecken ob ich mir noch was
fehlt und dann kommt es einfach nur noch
in den backofen später kommt noch gemüse
zum einsatz zeige ich euch aber gleich
[Musik]
also das fleisch war jetzt bei 180 grad
ober unterhitze für eine stunde und zehn
minuten im backofen dabei ist es egal ob
es wirklich eine stunde ist eine stunde
15 das ist halt anders als im kuchen
backen das schwurgericht braucht sowieso
eineinhalb bis maximal zwei stunden ich
habe mir nur gedacht so 40 minuten
ungefähr vor ende der zeit gebe ich noch
gemüse dazu und da nehme ich einfach
immer was ich da habt ihr könnt auch
kartoffeln nehmen ich habe jetzt hier
zum beispiel rote paprika und möhren da
hat jetzt zufällig wie das neg möhren da
liege ich jetzt einfach mit dazu ich
habe jetzt übrigens meine breitere
pfanne genommen als einfach ästhetischer
von uns sehen so das gebe ich jetzt
einfach rein
so dann nochmal den deckel drauf und in
40 minuten sehen wir uns wieder
[Musik]
übrigens müsst ihr danach nichts mehr
tun macht derzeit im backofen ist das
gericht fertig ihr müsst nichts an
dicken durch die zwiebeln ist es schön
sämig so leicht sehen mich so ich muss
also gezogen ich wusste dass es so
aussieht als es von der kritiker was
fleischgerichte angeht wird nicht
verwöhnt vorüber und von deiner mama
nadi ist von der sterneküche hier habe
ich noch salat aber gleichwohl richtig
sitzen und essen macht uns noch und
wir sind auseinander getrieben ist so 45
ist nach einer prima geflügel bohren
zwar kritisch heute
anerkannter test dass ich wurde
ausgebildet der krasseste kitchen also
was haben wir hier würden paprika oder
kaufen
gibt es auch im wege als ich nur sagen
and back and look and mitternacht gar
nicht benutzt würde grenzt ein meter
wegschmeißen es ist so zart ich einfach
glücklich
sie ist jetzt was ich mal gegeben mit
vorder video gefragt so nicht das kriegt
einfach kochen gemüse oder sollen wir
sie im übrigen
genau haben gemeint dass man die
gemüsebrühe weg wir nehmen barbara hat
und
weiß ich doch scheinbar ist sondern
glücklich dass es wirklich jetzt habt
immer als hätte ich weiß was smart cover
wie sie wissen haben wir es dann überall
hängen ja ich wusste wo noch aus der wir
nur noch chaos und chaos über dem
vorjahr
das ist so lecker also ich muß ich mach
selten schmorgerichte aber auch für uns
im alltag nicht mehr länger dauert aber
es ist gar kein aufwand also macht er
alles zack zack zack und der ofen
erledigte den rest und dann irgendwann
ist das essen fertig und die tolle
fahrer und die tolle gewürze sowie so
hat die gewürze machen wir machen uns
aus der uni konnte sagen was du willst
welche größe stunde jetzt zugewiesen
wird wer einen anderen geschmack durch
glaube ich bin total stehen beweist so
anspruchsvoll das pack ich nicht einfach
die sind diese diese arabische dienst
gewöhnt überlegen wollen so kannst du
das wirklich nur sieben gehört das habe
ich sonst noch was heftige salz pfeffer
und donnerstag das war es gar nicht so
eine ellenlange liste dass ein
exotisches supermärkte muss oder so
hammer kannst du dieses turnier wurde
das orchester dazu auf ihren papa da
probiert doch dann fühlte sich wieder
wie als kind sollen wo sie häufig
gekocht aber ich weiß nicht was du
redest von vier bretter turin da drin
ist und der torlinie aber ich hab das
hat sie oft dieser zeit andere leute
macht es um gegen nach wenn die gäste
ganz euch doch auch selbst
also ich gleich mal schmorgerichte aber
einfach zu folgen ja was denn also nicht
mehr so einer also du musst es gleich
auf reis tun ich wusste dass das war das
erste das musst du willst du einmal rein
schön flach und darüber dann hat gericht
und mit dieser seligen lächeln
das ist wie
du brauchst du ja ja so du warst in die
menschen etwas dazu also ich muss
das kriegt ja auch super chance den
ganzen rest aroma meinung unten in dem
zur burg jackmann rezept up expertin für
mich
okay aber richtig toll also diesmal mit
gleichungen
[Musik]